increasing about 1/4 the 1% of the
country to 2p not the knob students at
the academy to free poll world producer
recessional what prices differently than
I did 15 years ago 10 to go up stay up
there was Mike field that we have us
office it's always obvious Meccans were
inflated by spaces goes away you know
penofin scientist covered in Unitas miss
over comp uses scary scenarios to talk
to public make actual public Jaworski
evidence will be more on the link debate
on the camera but the possible arms of
hydrates global one good I'm a 12th
grader at Lexington High School I've
been involved in the policy debate team
for all four years of my high school
experience I've been doing debate since
my freshman year I didn't sign up for it
originally but when I was placed in it I
discovered a world of crazy
international relations and nuclear war
and all kinds of other bizarre things
that I just grew to love and I've been
debating ever since muster by renewable
problems price of this carry three
minutes well stage at capacity Jermaine
burger because again the prices even the
USS seated on roughly covering demand
for Oprah frankly I think Paul seemed to
be scares a lot of people it's just a
there's no extension from climate change
through I've seen 1102 temperatures
increased four degrees in the last 60
years ago the sea levels rose by three
by three meters and there's no no I
would skin Basquiat extinction due to
global warming which the reason who what
will increase the next 50 years ago it's
very high paced very fast not a lot of
people can understand it because people
are talking so quickly and if they did
understand what we were actually saying
they'd figure out that it was all kinds
of crazy scenarios from uh ashtar
galactic commands and several different
ways to lead to extinction
generally it isn't so much focused
around persuasion as in around as it is
around factual evidence and around the
line by line which is how arguments are
constructed in debate you lose me an
efficient events all about a lot it the
ten Americans considered intervention
technology we're seeing the concrete
Commission the Commission ended Vespa
awaiting the basic conditions if you're
taking out to be able to be balloons
miles wallet all those balloons in good
thing XP ogress they don't seem to work
demonstration within a planet it's like
it's don't ask kind of the initial
nemesis means there's no one that in the
policy debate community in order to be
part of the community you really have to
be there for a long time in order to
understand the debates in the first
place being prepared for policy debate
not only requires producing evidence on
a large scale and being able to answer
all your opponents positions that they
could read but it also requires doing
speed drills which are ways to increase
your ability to read fast during a
debate for example might put a pen in
their mouth and that would once
I don't know how to explain that this is
it's really weird why don't we do it do
stairs particular denims and please do
is partially domestic air space
employment and the most stressful and
hardest thing about debate for me is
just finding the time to find all the
evidence to answer on my opponents
arguments it seems like you see your
internal minkins you know from to our
attorney I'm planning on debating in
college but I don't really know what
else I'm gonna do it doesn't isolate a
specific waterworks all over it does
talk about the cold a second thought I
would like for evidence for a second
where do they go people a division to
get what you do Hartman a high-pressure
heater Russian economy the 5-11 no
sundress bites it's a spread for Cooper
to put 100 fives out to the public help
me grab a would fall crops that they do
new for Russian economy raising prices
you